நெலைக்கரி வைரமா மாறுது, ஒரு எலை கிழுளுவது, ஒரு மரத்துடைக்கில கிழுளுவது, மண்ணுக்கணையில் புதிந்து போதுவது.
ஆயிரம் ஆயிரம் வருஷம் கிழித்து நெலைக்கரியா மாறுது, அதுக்கும் ஐயாயிரம் வருஷம் கிழித்து வைரமா மாறுது.
இந்த செய்து கர்மா தான், ஆனால் இது நமக்கு மிகவும் சட்டல் வெள்ளை, அந்த கீழை எலை விழர்கள் மட்டும் தான் நமக்கு கண்ணுக்கு தெரியும்.
கிடைச்சியில் வைரமா கிடைக்குறது தெரியும், மட்டும் எதுவும் நமக்கு தெரியாதே நமக்கு கட்டுவலையில்லை.
அதை யார் செய்கிறான்? நமக்கு உள்ளே மைக்ரோலவெல்ல நடக்கிறது, இப்போது சாப்பாட்டை நான் சாப்பிட்டேன் என்பது தெரியும், இப்போது நான் எச்சல் முழுகினேன் என்பது தெரியும், அவ்வளவுதான்.
உள்ளே போய் அந்த சாப்பாட்டில் என்ன தொழில் நடக்கிறது? எனக்கு உள்ளேதான் நடக்கிறது.
ஆனால் எனக்கு தெரிய வேண்டாம் என்றால் சயின்ஸ்ல புக்களைப் படித்து தெரிந்துகொள்ளாம் என்று தவிரே, என்னால் அதைப் பிரச்சிவு செய்ய முடியாது, என்னுடைய நான்…
சட்டமே வரலி அவ்வளவு நேரம்…
சிறிது நிமிடம்…
நான் முதலில் திருணம் செய்கிறேன், நான் இப்போது ரத்தத்தை அந்த மனைவியைத் திடிக்க வைத்து, ரத்தத்தை அந்த குழாலை செலுத்துகிறேன், இதோ இப்போது ரத்தத்தில் இருக்கும் கால்சியம் சுட்டோன்ல, நம்முடைய எலும்புல் சென்று செல்லும்…
நம்முடைய குறிப்பதில் இல்லை, நான் செய்வதான் அவன் எனக்கும் இல்லை, ரத்தத்தில்தான் நான் இதை செய்கிறேன் என்று நமக்கு வரமாட்டேன், நம்முடைய குறிப்பதில் இல்லை, என்ன நடக்கிறது என்று தெரியாது.
குறிப்பதில் நம்முடைய குறிப்பதில் சுணாமியில் நடக்கிறது. இங்கும் ஒரு இந்தனையால் குறிப்பதில் நடக்கிறது, இங்கே சென்னையின் ஆகபாட்டனத்தில் சுணாமி வந்தது.
இந்தது அது உள்ள மக்ரோ தெரிய அளவில்லை, நம்முடைய சாய்சை விட தெரிய சாய்சை. இங்கும் ஒரு இடத்தில் சூரியனில் வந்து அந்த உணர்வுகள் இரண்டாலக்ஷம் கிலோமிட்டர் பத்திலக்ஷம் கிலோமிட்டர் நீழத்துக்கு குறிப்பதில் ஆகபாடுகிறது.
அது நம்ம செட்டிலைட்டு எல்லாம் எதிர்ந்து பயிறும் அப்படி இப்படி என்ன சொல்கிறான் என்று
சூரியனும் நம்ம கொண்டுல எல்லாம் அந்த சூரியனுடைய ஜோதிகள் அந்த ஜோலைகள்
வெளியராக இருக்கும் நம்ம கொண்டுல எல்லாம் அது எவ்வளவு தூரா வீடிச்சாகும்
பூமியோருக்கும் வருமா நம்ம உருவாக்கிய நகர்களையோ நம்ம உருவாக்கிய செட்டிலைட்டுகளையோ அழித்துவிடுமா எந்தும் நம்ம கொண்டுல வருகின்றோம்
சோ மக்ரோ சாய்ட்